--tapes.
And it made it more difficult.
And we are rolling.
So we were just discussing
the interviewer methodology.
And I-- if you're willing,
and you don't have to--
to comment, you
said that you used
to do five to seven
testimonies in one day, which
to me is mind-boggling.
I can't imagine doing that.
I can't imagine
the mental stamina
and the physical
stamina it takes.
And you said you swam to
kind of relieve yourself.
And you talked a little bit
about protective amnesia.
But at that point, you
were so immersed in it.
And also, five days
a week, working
as a psychiatrist, as-- as an
interviewer and as a survivor,
yourself, how did that
impact the process for you?
And do you think that,
in general, survivors
should be interviewers?
Should be interviewed?
Should be interviewers?
If I take myself as
a model, then, yes.
Of course, their own experience
is alive and awakened.
I think that part--
exans-- an example of that
is my interview of my mother,
that she spoke of experiences
that I was part of.
And they were the same.
Or they were
different, sometimes.
And there was, uh, moments
in which I pointed out
the difference and
moments I kept silent,
because she needed it to
tell it the way she told it.
Uh, I think the survivor
herself knows whether she
could be an interviewer or not.
You know, if it take-- there
may be people for whom this is
so, uh, upsetting, so--
uh, such-- causes such
an emotional storm,
that they shouldn't
be interviewer.
But they will know it.
And they will know it,
at least till they try.
And they know what-- they
find out that they do it.
It's-- I have a
lifelong training,
how to involve myself and
come back to m-- to the orig--
my original self, so.
And be completely
there, yet return.
Does it take a toll?
Yes.
Will I need to swim after this?
And I probably will go swimming.
Uh.
Is there any alternative
way to do it?
And I say this with
qualifications-- no.
You have to be all the
way there and to live it
and to struggle with
it and to feel it.
And sometimes, it's terrifying
in order to make it--
make it come into being.
You can stop faking.
No faking here.
Um.
So if survivors were--
are able to live a life,
they're also able to have an--
to do an interview and to,
uh, be in-- into themselves
and into the experience
they are sharing,
they are h-- they are
hearing, and the-- the impact
that the one has on the other.
Um.
Do, uh, particular
situations stir me up more?
Absolutely, uh,
particularly when
there's terror
involved, when, uh,
German uniforms are present.
And I'm not talking
empty uniform,
I'm talking with, uh,
the soldiers inside.
And I remember my own
moments of terror in that.
And, uh, maybe that's how I can.
The-- the person
interviewed feels
better understood
and better, um,
touched if they sensed that
they elicit something in me.
So, uh, do I pay a price for it?
Yes, I pay a price for it.
It's not-- I have to
bring myself back to--
What is terribly
important is that you--
interviewer feels
loved, that he's not--
not alone.
And, uh, I was very
fortunate in that way.
I felt loved as a child and
also throughout my life.
Um.
I think, you know, I'm free
associating, and that's OK.
I think that here is how
I married [? Johanna, ?]
who was able to not only cross
an ocean but cross a religion,
cross an experience, and
became an observant Jew.
And it was a way of
loving and being with me.
And, uh, that was
enormously empowering.
Uh.
So it's, uh, the
interviewed's relationship
but stemming from a--
a relatedness of the
interviewer, who can offer it.
Um.
And I think it continues
to be a relationship
after the interview is over.
And I found that, when
I re-interviewed people,
that we were-- there was a very
strong connection between us,
although we hadn't
spoken for decades.
Even, it was embarrassing that
I'd forgotten who they were.
And, uh--
But not the reverse?
Pardon?
No.
But not the reverse.
And, uh, I-- in some case,
I'd forgotten [INAUDIBLE] part
of their story.
But in others, I remembered
their story, very vividly.
And there are
psychological factors
why there is more forgetting
or less forgetting.
So when you did
these re-interviews,
you didn't watch
the first testimony
before you went in to
do the re-interview?
No.
I didn't want to do that, no.
I wanted to rely on
what I remembered.
And that was for another
project, not for us.
That was for another
project for--
uh, funded by the Slave Labor--
Right, right.
But when we did the
re-interviews here,
we did watch the
first testimonies.
I don't know if
you remember that.
I remember, vaguely, yes.
Right.
Yeah.
And, um, you know, that
was part of our protocol--
Yeah, yeah.
--in doing those re-interviews.
Um.
Going back to the-- the whole
development of this methodology
and the way you think about it
and the influence you've had,
um, and contrasting
it with others, it--
I think it's, um--
I don't want to use
the word "risky,"
but it takes a lot
more confidence--
Mhm.
--to do what you do
and to do what we do,
than it does to go in
with a set of questions.
Sure.
And I'm wondering-- and--
and it's risky to do what we
do, because we expose ourselves
to the potential of
hearing terrible--
I-- I-- there isn't words.
There aren't words to describe
some of the experiences
that we've heard.
But with a questionnaire,
you control that.
So it's much less risky.
Mhm.
Now, do you think that, in
spite of that questionnaire,
people can share those memories?
I think the
questionnaire is a buffer
and probably
reduces the sharing.
Except that there is a
internal pressure to tell
and a yearning to be heard.
So that's why, now, interviews,
simply making this available.
It wa-- the child was born.
It came out with
some help, sometimes.
So I think that, in spite
of the questionnaire,
people will speak and
say what is pressuring,
because it's a relief.
And there's this--
this yearning.
And whether-- at
least, they can--
for them, there can
be an imaginary, uh,
listener behind
that piece of paper,
that page with the questions.
Um, it's bo-- also likely that
the interviewer will interfere.
And it's enough that you show
that you don't want to hear,
and then it's all--
there's no story--
there's no testimony.
So, again, it-- it's
a wide spectrum.
In some situations, yes, the--
something will come through.
In others, it will
be chopped off.
Do you think that there's any
difference between those early
testimonies, that were taken
in the '70s and '80s, only--
I'm saying "only"--
30-something to
40-something years
after the experience,
and the later ones,
that you did re-interviews of--
of people who are now 60 and 70
years from this experience?
I-- I think the
time li-- time is--
uh, I don't think there's
a difference between '70s
and '80s and the--
the later ones.
There could be a difference
between '45, '47,
and the later ones.
And I've a little--
uh, uh-- studied them,
both their interviews.
Mhm.
And they have much more
a quality of immediacy
and of an appeal.
There's a message of
this-- the "shtetl brennt,"
to tell that maybe
some help will come in.
It's not yet over.
Uh, even, still rescue and
change the course of history.
That's a quality of the
immediate interview.
My daughters were taken
away, sent to Auschwitz.
But are they dead?
The question mark.
So those early
interviews are a--
have a quality of a cry for
help and for intervention.
Whereas the later
one, it's clear
that the daughter is dead.
And how does one deal with a
memory and the last moments?
And, uh, there's
work that has been
done, in the-- in the
interim, by the survivor.
But I do not know that there's
a difference between the 1970s,
'80s, and later on.
Yes, I-- what I can say
about the interviews,
that when I
re-interviewed people,
Leon's interview, the
first time, is one hour.
The second time is
two and a half hours.
Well, that was because you
only had one hour of tape.
We had 20-minutes tape then.
Tape.
But, you-- you know, it
was very limited, by the--
It was limited.
And so but who is the cause?
I think, it's also our
ways-- way of interview,
of knowing how to interview.
And it's a com-- very
more differentiated story,
that he was not only
a-- the thief of bread
but the bread bringer.
He worked in a bakery and
brought her, uh, bread, each--
and he used to extract the
bread through the window.
And then there were grates,
so it was two sticks.
That this cut up
the bread next time.
So he enourished his family, not
only took bread to his family,
nourished.
This was a very different.
So the first memory was like a
cover memory, a screen memory--
Mhm.
--that didn't tell
the full memory.
But is it Leon who has in--
uh, integrated more,
knows more with age,
or is it our interviewing that
was different 25 years later?
That's very interesting to me,
because, when we were doing
our re-interview project,
which was quite a bit earlier--
it was in the early to
mid-'90s-- and we asked Leon.
He said no.
He what?
He said?
He said no.
He didn't want to
be interviewed?
No.
He wouldn't be re-interviewed.
Interesting.
You know, we asked all
four of those original.
And two said yes,
and two said no.
And Leon said no.
So, you know, I'm just wondering
about the passage of time.
Yes.
Again, you are raising
questions that I
think should be studied in a
methodological, rigorous way.
And unfortunately, I don't
see that study happening.
Or maybe having the testimonies,
it will happen one day.
Well--
You asked me one thing
that I-- that I regretted,
that there's not
much more sub-facets
studied of the testimonies.
And there is--
Well, you need another lifetime.
I need another lifetime, yes.
For many things, I would--
I would accept it
with gratitude.
But I know what I have.
Now, is there anything else,
that I haven't asked, that you
think it's important to say?
I think we have covered.
Thank you for coming in today.
Thank you.